ونحن نشاهد الدخان يتصاعد بكثافه من هذه
المنطقه المستهدفه هذه المنطقه كانت تمثل
انفجار ثاني انفجار ثان ها الله انفجار
ضخم ضخم نحن نشاهد انفجار ضخم جدا
الان اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وسائل اعلام تابعه
لانصار الله تقول ان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا شنت غارات استهدفت منطقه الكثيب
في محافظه الحديده غربيه اليمن ومن جانب
اخر نشرت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه صورا
لما قالت انه انطلاق طائرات واطلاق صواريخ
على اهداف للجماعه بينما قال الناطق باسم
الجماعه محمد عبد السلام ان قرار اليمن
مسانده غزه ثابت ومبدئي ولا يتاثر باي
اعتداء وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
الرابط الموجود في التعليق الاول في اول
زياره لوزير خارجيه السودان الى ايران منذ
قطع العلاقات بين البلدين عام 2000 201
علي الصادق علي يلتقي في طهران وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان
وذلك لبحث العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
وطهران تؤكد ان الزياره تاتي في اطار
التنسيق لعوده العلاقات بين البلدين الى
مسارها الطبيعي قوات الامن السنغاليه تفرق
باستخدام الغاز المثير للدموع والعصي
مظاهرات في العاصمه دكار رافضه لقرار
الرئيس ماكي صال تاجيل الانتخابات الر
بينما اعرب رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه موسى
فكي عن قلقه من خطوه التاجيل ودعى السلطات
لتنظيم الانتخابات في اسرع وقت ممكن
السلطات في السلفادور تعلن فوز الرئيس
الحالي نجيب بوكيله الفلسطيني الاصل
بولايه رئاسيه ثانيه بعد حصوله على اكثر
من 85% من الاصوات ليصبح بذلك اول رئيس
للبلاد ينتخب لفتره ثانيه مدتها خمس سنوات
منذ ما يقارب ال عام الى
اللقاء